>> Chris: MARK MEREDITH
REPORTING FROM BRIDGEWATER,
NEW JERSEY.
MARK, THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE, NANCY PELOSI.
MADAM SPEAKER, WELCOME BACK TO
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY."
SPEAK TO MY PLEASURE TO BE WITH
YOU, GOOD MORNING, CHRIS.
>> Chris: PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
WHAT YOU WANT CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS WERE PUSHING YOUR
AGENDA, HE ACTED YESTERDAY TO
HELP PEOPLE IN NEED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER HAVE CHOSEN TO
HOLD THIS VITAL ASSISTANCE
HOSTAGE ON BEHALF OF VERY
EXTREME PARTISAN DEMANDS AND THE
RADICAL LEFT, DEMOCRATS, AND WE
JUST CAN’T DO THAT.
>> Chris: HOWEVER IT CAME
ABOUT, AND I KNOW YOU DON’T LIKE
THE EXECUTIVE ACTION, WON’T
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS NOW GET
SOME EXTENDED FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT RELIEF AND SOME
PROTECTION FROM EVICTIONS, GET
THAT NOW, RATHER THAN GETTING
NOTHING AT ALL?
>> Speaker Pelosi: NO, EFFECT
WITH THE PRESIDENT SAID, I WOULD
AGREE WITH HER WERE PUBLIC
SENATOR, UNCONSTITUTIONAL FLAW.
HAVE THE ILLUSION OF SAYING WERE
GOING TO HAVE A MORATORIUM ON
EVICTIONS, IT DOESN’T GOING TO
ASK THE FOLKS IN CHARGE TO STUDY
IF THAT’S FEASIBLE.
HE SAYS HE’S GOING TO DO THE
PAYROLL TAX, WHAT HE’S DOING IS
UNDERMINING SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE SO THESE ARE ILLUSIONS,
AND THEY REALLY DO NOT -- WHAT
HE CALLS IN OUR BILL
UNNECESSARY, THAT’S JUST REVIEW
THE DIFFERENCE.
FIRST OF ALL, MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN IN OUR COUNTRY ARE FOOD
INSECURE.
OUR BILL ADDRESSES THAT WITH
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
FEED THE CHILDREN.
THE REPUBLICAN BILL HAS $250,000
WHILE OUR BILL ADDRESSES THOSE
WHO ARE ON THE BRINK OF
EVICTION, WE USE THE NUMBERS
FROM THE PRINCETON EVICTION LAB
AND THE LOW-INCOME HOUSING
COALITION TO SHOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE WILL BE EVICTED AND WHAT
THEIR NEEDS ARE AND THAT COULD
COME TO TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
OF THE REPUBLICAN BILL HAS
NOTHING.
THIS BEING A SUNDAY MORNING, I
JUST RECALL A PRAYER THAT SAYS
PRAY FOR THOSE WHO ARE HUNGRY,
PRAY HARDER FOR THOSE WHO WILL
NOT FEED THEM.
PRAY FOR THOSE -- PRAY HARDER
FOR THOSE WHO WILL NOT GIVE THEM
SHELTER.
PRAY FOR THOSE WHO ARE SICK AND
LONELY, PRAY HARDER FOR THOSE
WHO WILL NOT GIVE THEM COMFORT.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID DOES NOT
ADDRESS SCHOOLS.
ALL OF THE ISSUES THAT ARE
CONTAINED IN THE LEGISLATION.
WE CAN GO THROUGH THAT, BUT YOU
SAID GIVE SHORT ANSWERS.
>> Chris: SPEAKER, I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PRESIDENT’S
EXECUTIVE ACTION DOESN’T DO ALL
THE THINGS THAT YOU WANT BUT
HAVING NO BILL AT ALL, NOT
COMING TO ANY AGREEMENT WASN’T
GOING TO PROVIDE ANY OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU WANT EITHER.
YOU’RE KNOWN AS A MASTER
NEGOTIATOR, BUT DIDN’T YOU
MESSED THIS ONE UP?
BECAUSE YOU TALK ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE PRESIDENT -- LET
ME JUST FINISH, IF I MAY,
SPEAKER.
NOW BECAUSE THERE’S NO DEAL AT
ALL, CITIES AND STATES WON’T GET
ANY MONEY, THERE’S NO MONEY FOR
THE POST OFFICE, THERE’S NO
MONEY FOR HOSPITALS, THERE’S NO
MONEY FOR STATE BOARDS OF
ELECTION.
YOU KNEW THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
THREATENING TO TAKE THIS
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WEREN’T
GOING TO GET EVERYTHING YOU
WANTED AND DIDN’T GET EVERYTHING
YOU WANTED, BUT SHOULD YOU HAVE
CUT A DEAL, AND ARE YOU READY TO
GO BACK INTO TALKS TO TRY TO
COME UP WITH A FULLER PACKAGE?
>> Speaker Pelosi: WHILE
CLEARLY YOU DON’T HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE BOTH IN THE
WEAKNESS OF THE PRESIDENT’S
EXECUTIVE ORDER, WHICH DON’T
GIVE THE MONEY, ENHANCED BENEFIT
BENEFIT, BUT THE FORMULA THERE
WILL TAKE A WHILE IF AT ALL TO
ACCOMPLISH TO PUT MONEY IN THE
POCKETS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT WE HAVE SAID, HONOR OUR
HEROES, STATE AND LOCAL,
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, ET CETERA,
FIRST RESPONDERS, TEACHERS AND
THE REST.
AND AS PART OF OUR ARGUMENT, HOW
MUCH ARE THEY WILLING TO DO?
SECONDLY, WE ARE GOING TO STOP
THE --
>> Chris: BUT SPEAKER --
>> Speaker Pelosi: I ALLOWED
YOU TO FINISH, YOU ALLOW ME TO
FINISH.
THEY ARE GOING TO -- LET’S OPEN
OUR ECONOMY BY ADDRESSING THE
VIRUS, WHICH THE PRESIDENT HAS
IGNORED FOR MONTHS NOW, TO DO
THE RIGHT THING’S,
SCIENTIFICALLY-BASED AND THIRD,
LET’S PUT MONEY IN THE POCKETS
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID
DOESN’T EVEN ACCOMPLISH WHAT HE
SETS OUT TO DO IN THE CATEGORIES
HE DID.
BUT WE SAID TO THEM, WE WILL
COME DOWN A TRILLION, YOU GO UP
A TRILLION.
MEET US HALFWAY AND WILL BE ABLE
TO HAVE AN AGREEMENT THAT MEETS
THE NEEDS OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
PEOPLE.
>> Chris: I UNDERSTAND,
SPEAKER, BUT THE POINT I’M
TRYING TO MAKE IS, THEY WERE
OFFERING $150 BILLION FOR CITIES
AND STATES.
YOU WANTED 900 BILLION.
THE RESULT OF NO DEAL IS THAT
THE STATES AND CITIES, WHICH WE
ALL AGREED DO NEED SOME MONEY
COMEAU IS GOING TO GET NOTHING.
IT IS THE QUESTION IS -- I’M NOT
SAYING IT’S ALL YOUR FAULT
ANYMORE THAN IT’S ALL THE
REPUBLICANS FAULT, BUT THE
FAILURE TO MAKE A DEAL IS GOING
TO RESULT IN A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
A LOT OF ENTITIES THAT WERE IN
NEED ENDING UP WITH NOTHING.
>> Speaker Pelosi: WELL, HOW
DO YOU JUSTIFY?
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
FEED THE HUNGRY TO DO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
TO UNDERSTAND HOW FAR APART WE
ARE?
JUST BY THAT EXAMPLE.
LET’S BRING ALL OF THAT
TOGETHER.
YOU CONTENDS THAT THEY ARE
PUTTING UP MONEY FOR ELECTIONS.
NO, NO.
YOU CONTENDS THEY’RE HELPING
WITH THE POST OFFICE.
NONE OF THAT IS IN THEIR BILL.
IF SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
AMOUNTS THAT ARE IN THEIR BILL,
IT DOESN’T HAVE ANY OF THAT.
OUR BILL DOES.
BUT LET’S PUT IT THIS WAY.
WE HAVE TO REACH AN AGREEMENT.
CHILDREN ARE FOOD INSECURE,
FAMILIES AT THE RISK OF BEING
EVICTED.
THE VIRUS IS MOVING LIKE A
FREIGHT TRAIN EVEN THOUGH THE
PRESIDENT HAS IGNORED AND
DELAYED AND DISTORTED WHAT THAT
IS.
SOMETHING IS WRONG WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THOSE EXECUTIVE ORDERS,
EITHER THE KINDEST THING I COULD
SAY, HE DOESN’T KNOW WHAT HE’S
TALKING ABOUT OR SOMETHING IS
WRONG THERE, SOMETHING IS VERY,
VERY WRONG THERE, SO TO
CHARACTERIZE THEM AS EVEN
ACCOMPLISHING WHAT THEY SET OUT
TO DO AS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
TAKE THE PLACE OF AN AGREEMENT
IS JUST NOT SO.
>> Chris: YOU SUGGESTED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES NOT HAVE
THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO DO WHAT
HE DID YESTERDAY.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT GOING TO
COURT TO MAKE BECAUSE IF YOU DO,
YOU MUST KNOW THAT A PRACTICAL
EFFECT OF THAT WOULD BE, IF
YOU’RE SUCCESSFUL, THAT YOU
WOULD BE BLOCKING -- I KNOW YOU
THINK THAT THEY SHOULD BE $600
RATHER THAN $400, BUT YOU WOULD
BE BLOCKING, IF YOU ARE
SUCCESSFUL, THE MILLIONS OF
UNEMPLOYED WORKERS FROM GETTING
ANY FEDERAL BENEFITS.
>> Speaker Pelosi: TWO THINGS,
FIRST OF ALL, YOUR LAST POINT.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT PUT FORTH WAS
A COMP LOOK FORMULA WHICH SAID
THAT THE STATES SHOULD PUT UP
25%.
IT STATES DON’T DON’T HAVE THE
MONEY TO DO THAT.
THEY HAVE EXPENSES FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS.
THEY HAVE LOST REVENUE FROM
SHELTER IN PLACE AND THE FACT
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT BEING ABLE
TO GO OUT AND SPEND MONEY AS
THEY WOULD NORMALLY, BUT APART
FROM THAT, THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF THAT IS A DIFFERENT QUESTION.
RIGHT NOW WE NEED TO COME TO
AGREEMENT.
WHICH GOT TO MEET HALFWAY.
WE’VE GOT TO MAKE IT -- THE BEST
WE CAN FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE PUTTING FORTH
DOES NOT MEET THAT STANDARD.
IT COULD.
AND WE CARE SO MUCH ABOUT THE
FACT THAT PEOPLE ARE IN NEED.
OUR CHILDREN WANT TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
OUR PARENTS WANT THEM TO GO, AS
A GRANDMOTHER AND AND A MOM, I
UNDERSTAND THE ANGST THAT IS
WITH THAT, BUT WITH THE
PRESIDENT THAT DIDN’T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT.
SO THE PRESIDENT’S MEAGER, WEAK,
AND ONTO CONSTITUTIONAL
ACTIONS -- UNCONSTITUTIONAL
ACTIONS FOR THE DEMAND THAT WE
HAVE AN AGREEMENT IN ANY
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION IS A
SEPARATE ISSUE.
>> Chris: SPEAKER, I WANTED TO
GET TWO QUESTIONS AND GRADE IF
YOU DO RESUME TALKS, AND YOU SAY
YOU WANT TO -- AND I’M NOT
SAYING THAT THIS IS ALL ON YOU
AS OPPOSED TO THE REPUBLICANS,
BUT WHY SHOULD WE EXPECT THE
TALKS WILL BE ANY MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS THAT WENT NOWHERE?
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS BE WILLING TO
BE MORE FLEXIBLE?
>> Speaker Pelosi: WE SAID WE
WOULD COME DOWN A TRILLION.
IT DOESN’T MEAN THAT WE HAVE
THINGS IN THEIR WE WOULD CUT
OUT, IT MEANS THAT WE COULD TALK
ABOUT HOW LONG OUR PROVISIONS
WOULD BE IN EFFECT, SO WE CAN
TAKE THINGS DOWN, AND HEAD OF --
INSTEAD OF THE END OF SEPTEMBER
NEXT YEAR, SHORTER PERIOD OF
TIME AND WE WILL REVISIT ALL OF
IT NEXT YEAR.
SO BY EXCHANGING SOME OF THAT --
CHANGING SOME OF THE TIMING, WE
CAN COME DOWN BUT BY AND LARGE
WHAT WE HAVE IN THE BILL
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WE HAVE
JUST -- AND PART OF THE TIME IT
HAS TAKEN FOR US TO GO BACK AND
FORTH IS TO DEMONSTRATE TO
REPUBLICAN NEGOTIATORS THE
JUSTIFICATION, THE DOCUMENTATION
OF WHAT IT MEANS IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE NEED FOR FEEDING THE
HUNGRY, WHAT WE NEED FOR HELPING
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
EVICTED.
WHAT WE NEED FOR SCHOOLS.
>> Chris: SPEAKER, I
UNDERSTAND ALL THAT.
I FELT ONE LAST QUESTION I’D
LIKE TO GET IN IN THE TIME ON A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SUBJECT.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY CAME
OUT WITH A REPORT THIS WEEK THAT
SAYS THAT THE RUSSIANS ARE
TAKING THEIR WORDS, A RANGE OF
MEASURES TO UNDERCUT JOE BIDEN
AND TO HELP PRESIDENT TRUMP GET
REELECTED, BUT THEY ALSO SAID
THAT CHINA AND IRAN VERY MUCH
WANT TO SEE THE PRESIDENT
DEFEATED.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE FROM BOTH SIDES?
>> Speaker Pelosi: NO.
WHAT I’M CONCERNED ABOUT IN THE
INTELLIGENCE REPORT, AND WE HAVE
LEADER SHERMER -- EXCUSE ME
SCHUMER AND I, CHAIRMAN SCHIFF
AND VICE CHAIRMAN, WHATEVER THEY
CALL IT IN THE SENATE, HAVE
WRITTEN TO SAY YOU HAVE TO
RELEASE THE INFORMATION.
NOT SOURCES AND METHODS, BUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT THE RUSSIANS ARE DOING IN
THIS CASE AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD
DECIDE WITH THE NEXT PRESIDENT
IS, NOT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THEY TRY TO BLANKET IT WITH THE
CHINESE, THEY SAID, PREFER
BIDEN -- WE DON’T KNOW THAT, BUT
THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE SAYING, BUT
THEY’RE NOT REALLY GETTING
INVOLVED IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
I’VE BEEN A CRITIC OF TRAN OF
OVER 30 YEARS, I TAKE SECOND
QUESTION ON MY CRITICISM OF
CHINA, BUT FOR THEM TO GIVE SOME
EQUIVALENTS IS NOT RIGHT.
IT DOESN’T REALLY TELL THE
STORY.
BUT AS LONG AS THEY TELL THE
WHOLE STORY ABOUT RUSSIA, THEN
THEY CAN HIDE IT ANY WAY THEY
WANT, THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NEED TO KNOW.
THIS IS OUR SACRED RIGHT, THIS
IS OUR ELECTIONS AND IN EVERY
WAY WE MUST MAKE SURE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE REMOVE OBSTACLES
OF PARTICIPATION AND OBSTACLES
IN TERMS OF INTELLIGENCE TO MAKE
SURE THEY KNOW WHAT’S AT STAKE.
>> Chris: SPEAKER, IN THE
HOPES OF NEGOTIATIONS, I’M GOING
TO TAKE YOU OFF THE STAGE AND
PUT SECRETARY MNUCHIN ON SO HE
GETS TO TALK AS WELL.